for the motion is Lionel Shriver author
of 12 novels including the bestsellers
the mandibles and the orange orange
prize-winner We Need to Talk About Kevin
a prolific journalist as well whose
writing has appeared in The Guardian The
New York Times The Telegraph the
spectator The Wall Street Journal and
many other publications so Lionel for
the motion please do take to the podium
and a round of applause
[Applause]
who are you most of us spend our lives
trying to evolve a nuanced sense of
ourselves but as far as the identity
politics cabal is concerned if you're an
anglo-saxon professor of economics at
UCL with a child whose drug addiction
has broken your heart a sideline as a
stand-up comic and a passion for polka
dancing all you are is white worse
privileged meaning you should be ashamed
of yourself and none of your
achievements are to your credit for the
term identity politics implies a
worldview the dogma couches human
history exclusively in terms of unequal
power relationships between groups thus
all of life reduces to human hierarchy
an individual's identity derived solely
from membership of a collective in the
service of a revolutionary social
justice your rights will right to be
heard to avail yourself of social
resources and to defend your own
interests depend entirely on your having
been marginalized due to race race
ethnicity sexual preference gender or
disability hilariously the bulk of
identity politics Crusaders are actually
well-off white people competing over who
can be more righteous I grew up during
the civil rights and women's liberation
movements in the United States I was a
fierce advocate of both but the goal of
these earlier campaigns was to break
down the artificial barriers between us
and to release us all into seeing each
other not as black or white or male or
female but as individual people granted
with race and sex we've still got a ways
to go but one of the greatest
impediments to fully breaking free of
our pigeonholes is the rise of identity
politics for we all fall into categories
that weren't of our choosing I was born
white female and American no one asked
me beforehand whether I wanted to tick
those boxes and they are boxes so I've
never wanted these categories to define
me as I wouldn't want the categories
into which the folks in this audience
were unwillingly born to define you
either the color of my skin is an
arbitrary accident not a personal brand
as a woman I often break the mold I'm
outspoken and sometimes unpleasantly
aggressive I dress badly I even make a
pretty lousy American having spent most
of my adult life in the UK for me the
boxes into which I was born had been
confinements I've struggled to get out
of and I would wish that liberation for
everyone else identity politics urges us
all instead to cling to the bars of our
cages in locating advantage in
disadvantage to the movement pushes
historically marginalized groups to
deploy weakness as a weapon thus you're
strongly motivated to maintain that
weakness the better to push other people
around with the unfairness of your
terrible plight perversely then victims
of racism sexism or homophobia say
logically grow attack attached to the
very prejudiced from which they suffer
because prejudice translates into power
and without victimhood they have no idea
who they are
ironically the last thing the archetype
identity politics crowd wants to see is
a truly equitable society absent bigotry
its activists would be lost identity
politics doesn't eliminate human
hierarchy but simply flips the totem
pole upside down thus at the very bottom
sit awful undeserving Lee advantaged
white people and at the very very bottom
white straight males who according to
this Creed have no rights and no
business venturing an opinion
anything who are obliged to check their
privilege aka shut the [ __ ] up
well I reject out of hand that any group
should be told they have no rights and
they have to put a sock in it I happen
to be married to a white straight male
and I'm often very interested in what he
has to say
according to identity politics the sins
of the father are visited visited upon
the sons if you're white you accept
responsibility for slavery colonialism
and the slaughter of native peoples from
Australia to America but do we really
believe in infinitely inherited guilt
let's all be historically clear-eyed but
Germans coming of age today oughtn't to
feel personally responsible for Dachau
nor should any of us pretend to feel
guilty about something we know perfectly
well we didn't do have you noticed how
many headlines these days involve race
how as sociologist Documenta steady
decline in racial prejudice relations
between races seem to be getting worse
that's because this movement is
inherently adversarial it thrives on
enemies though ostensibly concerned with
victimhood its proponents gleefully seek
victims of their own identity Rian's
have created a cutthroat predatory
environment in which often anonymous
self-appointed culture police prowl the
halls of the internet searching for
perceived violations of their
orthodoxies using the wrong word
reaching for the wrong pronoun allowing
that amidst all the plunder and
domination maybe countries colonized by
Britain enjoyed one or two teeny-tiny
benefits can now get you set for this
movement has issued and not the color
and gender blindness we aspire to in my
youth but a hyper awareness of race
gender and ethnicity implicitly the
ideology
it's disadvantaged groups against one
another in a competition over who's been
treated more badly rather than calling
us to a shared community it fosters a
climate of anxiety division antagonism
touchiness and paranoia
so in our universities faculties are
terrified to teach or publish anything
that might conceivably step on a
minorities toes self-censorship is rife
persecution common in workplaces
employees negotiate a minefield of
microaggressions and are afraid to make
jokes in my occupation fiction is vetted
by sensitivity readers while many of my
fellow writers are frightened of
crafting characters different from
themselves lest they break a host of
proliferating unwritten rules in social
settings many of us have if anything
grown less likely to approach a stranger
of a different race and not because
we're bigots but because we're fearful
that we might inadvertently say the
wrong thing I don't call that progress
inexorably to identity politics has
conjured the boogeyman of white identity
politics now on the rise in the u.s. if
we're all to understand each other in
terms of our helpless membership of
groups white people are going to
understand themselves in those terms as
well and it's interesting how
unattractive it is to brandish your skin
color as the most important aspect of
your sense of self when white people
start doing it - certainly many of the
folks staging this festival of taking
offense are well intended we should all
be alert to the fact that others may
have experienced social and professional
travails that we haven't yet surely the
power dynamics of human hierarchies
can't explain everything looking out the
window and seeing only degrees of
victimhood is a flat oppressive
reductive and depressing way of looking
at the world
sometimes it's a relief to think about
something else
architecture color and light outer space
so I for one do not plan on embracing my
skin color or my gender or sexual
preference as the cynic wa known of my
character for I reject outright the very
concept of identity that this poisonous
overtly racist and sexist outlook
promotes I like dancing to Talking Heads
I'm a big fan of Graham green Richard
Yates and Edith Wharton I've published
thirteen books of my own and whatever
their failings those novels are a part
of who I am I love the word mellifluous
I over used the word insidious I have a
weakness for Poldark I'm a mediocre
tennis player who makes up for her
deficits on the court with Shira Byul
Ian's that and more is my identity so if
anyone aims to put Lionel Shriver
straight white female on my tombstone
I'm definitely getting cremated
[Applause]
you